hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
welcome to this week's winners on a
wednesday
over the last 12 years i've done
hundreds of property deals however this
week i'm going to introduce you to
alistair cunningham and alastair
came as a student how many years ago
were you did you come as a student just
over three years
just over three years yeah and this dude
it took me four years to become
financially free
this dude did it in three months and
since becoming financially free you've
gone on to do hundreds of property deals
yeah so you're
probably you're probably the most
successful student if not one of them
that i've had and it's a real honor to
now be a friend um
and uh why don't you just give a little
bit of insight about what you're doing
now and then we'll go through what
happened well yeah obviously
we met like mid-2016 and
i was like so like
i was inspired by you but i was very
skeptical of you because that's just me
i was skeptical as you call me skeptical
score
very skeptical and then i just came and
i got involved and i've done it and i
went through that i played full out
and i got one property then i got
another property
and then i got some lease options then
i've done deal sourcing and now like
i've got a property portfolio i've got
passive income
i've got deal sourcing business which is
systemized i'm training i'm speaking so
i'm speaking on the very stages that i
was skeptical about
and it's crazy it's just crazy but the
journey of what happened
it i mean if people only knew where you
are now
yeah yeah and where you've come from
like the story
like oh i pinch myself yeah and you may
even probably pinch yourself hundred
percent
do you know what's interesting i um met
um a student that signed up for the
training exact same event i did the
other day
and i was actually running an event he
was a delegate and he
was like i can't what i cannot believe
the transformation
yeah and he was very like really really
heartfelt as well so it was really nice
and he was like
wow you've just changed so much as a
person as a trainer as a speaker as a
businessman
and just all round and it's like you've
even written a book
yeah you've even written a book uh
what's it called whatever it takes why
did you call it that
because you helped me with that because
you said you do whatever it takes and i
remember you said you
were just chatting one day and you said
you know why you're successful because
you're prepared to do whatever it takes
yeah that's right i said that sounds
like a good book claim
so i just went for it but i think it's
so true i think
you know and your book by the way is is
a fabulous book yeah it's
it's one of the few property books
that's probably better than my property
book
but you know it's a fabulous book but is
it so true and we've we've done so much
together we've yeah we've we've uh
we've almost died together on the river
nile in africa yeah
i still get flashbacks mates yeah
literally maybe we could talk briefly
about that but we've done so much
together and i see you now as a brother
and i think that though in order to win
you know if you're if you're
if you're starting from nothing yeah
you're starting from very little in
order to win i think you do need to
prepare to whatever it takes because
you know and some of those people people
criticize me for making it look too easy
which i take as a compliment by the way
because it's like saying christina i
don't know how to make football look too
easily
saying i don't make problems that ease
is a good thing but you know
whatever you do in life is going to be
hard work if you're going to have a job
it's hard if you're going to be an
entrepreneur it's hard if you're being
fat it's hard and being slim is hard
like
it's whatever you're going to do is hard
but to achieve what you've achieved is
do whatever it takes
so talk me through right from the very
beginning and then i want to draw
lessons out of what happened so
how did this all start um okay so it
started by me seeing you on tv
uh weak landlords move in yeah that was
a bbc show
yeah ironically that was the bbc
actually making me look bad
yeah well did bbc have a great knack if
trying to make it bad i didn't think you
looked bad from it did you not no not at
all
even though i was not at all the greedy
landlord no i didn't see that
do you know honestly do you know what i
thought yeah i thought he's just a
landlord
and like when you went into that lady's
house and the plaster was falling out
yeah so it's not your fault you're the
landlord you're not the manager
yeah so maybe your management didn't
tell you things i don't see that as a
bad thing what's interesting is though
when the tv trying to set me up and make
me look bad
what people don't realize is they're
still giving me exposure yeah
you know like if the newspapers are
saying stuff trying to paint me in a bad
light
you know like channel four did with joe
lifestyle how many people have come
through our businesses
because they're watching and they go oh
that looks a bit awful that's weird and
then they
actually check the facts and then they
go the thing is
we speak at this a lot right negative
people will always be associated with
negativity so they'll love it they'll
thrive in it
but people like me now me back then
i would have been the negative one yeah
but i still would have looked okay but
now
i don't even fall into that negativity
now i'll fact-check can i look into
something so if i hear a story about
anybody i'll always look into it
okay so see me on the tv yeah saw you on
tv um i
came to the crash course yeah um i'm
talking about whatever it takes right
and i we see this a lot people come up
with excuses why they can't oh
how long is the crash course like the
crash course that's coming next week
yeah i've had messages people saying
how long is it how many how many hours
is it i'm like does it matter yeah you
want to learn so do whatever you say
next week
the day after tomorrow yeah well pretty
much yeah
my point being is people message you
saying well how long is it going to be
where is it
it's in uk yeah get there i missed my
brother's wedding
to come to the crash course dude i
remember i remember you messaged me on
facebook and you said i'm not able to
come to the crash course this year yeah
is this the last one of the year i'm not
able to come i'll come next year
and and i'm going to turn into a
paternity fifth ruby
yeah and you were going to be off for
like six seven months yeah and i thought
well if i don't go i'll not go so i need
to go
yeah and um i unfortunately i missed my
brother's wedding that time but we're
good now but i miss my brother's wedding
time to come
and then i was still very skeptical all
of day one
i was like hmm really he's making it
sound very easy
really and then on day two um
when you you offered to do never use
your money again
um i was still like i wanted to do it
but i was like
like two grand was a lot of money yeah
back then and i was like
and then um lisa said just
stop messing about and just go and do it
yeah
and i've done it and then i came to the
listen by the way your partner
we said yeah and wife and um
i i don't think if it was felicia being
i don't think you'd have i wouldn't have
made i wouldn't obviously
have to give we have to give uh massive
price she's a fabulous fabulous like
yeah a hundred percent hundred percent
and um i am i came to find extravagance
and the usual one again
yeah and i actually left and i know i've
told you about this before but
i got to the venue and my whole negative
mindset came back in
what is that negativity where does it
come from scottish mate
because is it scottish i mean scottish
skepticism yes they're like
yeah and i remember you saying to me you
were like just look me in the eye and
tell me that this is true
i did just lock me in the eye and i
looked you in the eye i was like
i can't promise it's gonna work for you
but it works do you know simon
um i'll tell you that in a minute but
where it comes from is i've been brought
up
think if it sounds too good be true
always is yeah and i'm sure everyone's
heard that okay
um and you you sort of you're led to
believe that if you want anything in
life you have to work your
ass off for it physical hard labor and i
come from a family of labour of
of um joiners builders carpenters like i
was a bus and coach mechanic i was
getting filthy dirty every single day
fixing buses and coaches and i was
working hard
to make money and i was doing all right
i wasn't skin i was doing all right
but i wasn't making big money and then
you showed me a way of
instead of working harder still work
hard but combine that with working
smarter
yeah and that's what i took away from
that's what i learned from you work
smarter not harder
still work hard but work smarter at the
same time and that's what i was doing
and
i came to the the dfe and again i was
still a little bit skeptical i actually
left the venue
when you left what do you mean so i
arrived at the morning on day one
registered my nerves kicked in my
anxiety kicked in
because i was like only like there was
like 25 people there and thought
is it really that easy and i thought you
know what this is gonna be a waste of
three days
a waste of three days and i i got back
in my car and i left and i phoned my
wife up and said i'm just gonna go to
work and not and not
we've spent two grand it's it's not
going to work for us then she's cool
and then she said don't be stupid get
back there so i went back eventually she
was really like
coaching you through it yeah yeah she
was mad more than people know yeah and
i went back and i got involved
and then day one i was just i was doing
what everyone was doing i was just
getting involved
but then what done it for me was in the
evening
you might remember us i don't know but
in the evening we were all sat
downstairs having
just chilling out having a chat and a
few drinks and then i was sat with a guy
who was very shy very very shy
and he went to bed and i was left on my
own and you saw me
you didn't know me then really but you
come over you made the effort to come
make go out away from the crowd come
over
and just sit and say hey how are you
doing how are you getting on what you
enjoying what you're not enjoying
and that was the moment where i actually
thought actually he's actually not a bad
guy
i went from actually not distrusting you
but i went from thinking
like he's just trying to sell to me to
actually he does care yeah and then that
was what made me
then sit up pay attention and then the
next day when we i was speaking to you
about the academy
um and i yeah i did i shook your hand i
wouldn't let go your hand i looked too
nice and said
yeah you remember that yeah i remember
it and it was so funny because
i actually remember coming sitting and
speaking to you as well and
at the time i just thought oh i don't
even think i need you know
i just thought oh you know he looks like
he's on his own hope he's okay yeah i'm
gonna sit with him
little did i know and this is a really
important lesson for me now that small
act of just not even kindness it's not
even but just that act of
caring about people as small as that
there if i hadn't have done that
then that may not have that might have
meant that
you parted companies i wouldn't have the
friend
the success student the trainer the the
business partner
yeah that i have just that wouldn't
you're right that wouldn't have happened
because i wouldn't
i wouldn't have joined the academy yeah
because my negativity and my skepticism
was still there
but you broke that a little bit by just
caring and you didn't even talk about
houses you didn't even talk about
property
i don't remember exactly what you said
but it wasn't about it wasn't like oh
you've got to sign up for academy
none of that it was just how are you
finding it are you enjoying it can i
help you with anything yeah like
tell me about yourself it was so
important yeah such an important lesson
and it made me
realize that actually you are a caring
guy and then
i come on to the academy i went off
found some deals co-sourced at the time
sold nine deals in nine weeks made 27
grand or something like that
let me just say the negative though real
quick you go on you did the training
yeah the deal finding extravaganza never
germany again you spent a few thousand
pounds or whatever it was
you then went off and all the viewings
that you booked from the from the course
fell through they didn't work they were
done houses
is that right they were yes but knowing
what i know now they were all perfect
houses
yeah at the time i thought wow this
needs so much work
but to me now the perfect buy
refurbished refineries
right i haven't done the buy before
training at this point yeah so i've only
done deal finance driving and never use
your money which gave me
enough information that's why you're on
the academy that's why i joined their
class
okay so the houses that you saw then
didn't work yeah how did you feel at
that point did you feel do you motivated
did you want to question
100 okay what happened i'll say i've
done full day of viewings
because i chose hull as my area full day
of viewings and i remember i looked at
like nine or ten houses in one day
all of them sucked and i remember in the
back of my car piles of paperwork you
know like when you first start you're
very eager so you have a flip chart you
have
you have viewing forms you have all the
pdfs from all the properties and they're
all in the backseat and they were just
notes everywhere
and i'm like i told you this doesn't
this doesn't work
this doesn't work and i remember the
very last viewing i met a lady called
amy as a station called amy
and she said look i've got another one
you can view tomorrow
and i'm like well i'm not actually here
tomorrow but you know what i'll stay
over so i stayed in to i went into the
ibis and
uh hall city center stayed over one
night whatever it takes yeah i'm
prepared to do that yeah
and um i went to that view in the next
day
and that viewing was a property in hull
and it was a fully reformed four bed hmo
and i actually sold that to an investor
two days later wow
so because i stayed and that made me
think actually this does work if you put
the effort in yeah see i was prepared
i nearly got to a point where in day one
i'm like yeah i told you i'll give it a
bash
let's give up i'm gonna be really really
honest and vulnerable for a moment right
here actually
um i i didn't plan on talking about this
but
when you when we spoke at the deal
phoning extravaganza and you joined the
academy yeah i remember telling you
that any properties that you've found uh
we'd help you sell with kodi or source
but we didn't there was a little bit of
a misunderstanding
oh there was a little bit yeah between
the commission split which was to be
honest
was on me yeah i hadn't been cleared
properly and
i had given the impression
that we would split the fee 50 50. yeah
yeah
but in actual fact i was offering how
much
i don't know like a few questions yeah
not not a lot of money right
which was totally my bad yeah okay tony
about that
and you then brought started bringing a
couple deals to me and like can you sell
these and i was like yeah i can sell
them
and then when it went over to our
finance team and russell got involved in
that russell's like okay here's how the
structure works here's how the
commission works
and you were like that's not the
impression i got from samuel yeah yeah
russell came to me and said dude what
did you say why is alistair
and it wasn't just you there was a cut
there was also stuart brown what what
why are these guys under the impression
that you said this and i was like to be
honest i didn't know what the actual
deal was myself yeah so i'm ringing you
up
and saying let me clap you wrong on a
sunday right
i don't know if you know that yeah if
you remember you wrote me on a sunday
mate
and i'll tell you what yes fine there
was a little bit of confusion i messed
up you did yes
but you rung me on because i sold i
think six or seven deals by this point
and i was expecting okay great i've got
this money coming to me right you run me
up and goes duke i've messed up and
um and completely open and honestly you
said it's my bad i've messed up
um so what do you want to do and you
actually said to me
dude if you want to just shake hands as
friends we'll park company i'll give you
all your money back and we'll park
company and i'm like no way
it's not happening i'm not sure dude you
ain't getting rid of me yeah i say and
you said well what do i need to do to
make this right
and i said honor what you said and then
from this point forward we'll fully use
and that's what we've done yeah you're
honest what you said again just strong
that motivated me to start my own deal
sourcing business yeah
so good i'm fine thank you yeah
so many lessons in this though because
number one i dropped up i messed the
board i messed up right
but then i said to you how can i put
this right yeah of course you want your
money back what do you want to do yeah
you told me we agreed but then as a
result of that because you're thinking
i don't want to be taking a few hundred
quid yeah from samuel's company
um you were like you said to me how do i
find my own investors talk what happened
because
this is powerful it's true um so what
happened was um
you said to me because there was a
little bit of confusion you said okay
come to the office on monday
bring one deal um i brought three deals
well then i said i'll do that deal you
said you would help me
sell that to an investor yeah and you
should show me yeah you would show me
um essentially deal selling yeah so i i
came to the office at hilton home monday
morning
i had three property deals that i was
working on i brought them to you by 11
o'clock
we'd sold them to investors money in the
bank we were sat in a pub having lunch
yeah that's true i remember and that was
the start of the deal cell master class
it was which we'll get onto how did you
feel like what actually happened on that
day because i remember saying to you i
remember saying
dude bring me a deal right come to my
office
i'll sell the deal in front of you and
i'll show you the whole system of how to
find investors sell deals
what'd you do and i basically put
together a little program
yeah for you yeah which now we've
adapted which we'll come on to
but what happened on that day on the day
i arrived
you looked at the deals we done due
diligence we sent an email out to my
list to your list
and we just literally hold your phone up
bing bing bing bing bing constantly what
was the thing
and the text message is investors
texting in saying yeah show me show me
the deal show me the deal show me the
deal
i want it i the thing is once you see it
you can't unsee it yeah
that was the biggest motivation i ever
needed yeah seeing that was the biggest
motivation i ever needed
and because i'm like i work my ass off
to earn two and a half grand a month
and we're selling the deal making two
and a half brand in an hour but you
didn't just bring one deal you brought
three
and we saw that why did you bring three
because i do two reasons
one because i always i like to over
deliver on everything i do yeah and
secondly i knew i was being cheeky
because i thought if i bring three you
might sell all three yeah i was just
being cheeky
and i knew that i i knew that if you
you're the sort of person that if you if
if we if an academy member
or somebody that's doing training
whatever does one you'll
multiply you so you make it one move you
make 10. that's what i always say yeah
questions you've got
and sometimes people say why are you
spending so much time with all this
stuff people used to say that yeah
it used to be called golden boy yeah
yeah from yeah but
it was annoyed people used to say why
spend so much time around stare
i'm like because when i tell lester to
do something
he does it times three yeah yeah right
when i tell you to do the same thing
you come up with an excuse yeah i just
does it so
i as an investor i'm an investor not
just to my money plus
my time yeah i'm gonna spend more time
with people so i put this little program
together
not only do we get loads of text coming
through on my phone but then i pick up
the phone
you hear me say hey are you selling and
that's you're selling you
you're a good salesman and there's
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
i i love sales
of course it is and and actually hearing
you pick the phone up to investors and
sell to them
really good yeah like seriously it
opened my eyes because
i was very much like you can't be you
can't sell because it's dirty and
like oh sailing's crazy no i love
selling you've got to filter them first
make sure they want it sell to them so i
sold three deals there and then they
were your deals
yeah um as a result of that you went on
to set up your own company which is
actually i'm a silent partner yeah you
are
um better for transparency and we take a
nice dividend from that each week
we get that's passive yeah do you know
what people say you can't systemize deal
source unlike it
yeah like so talk to me about that
because after that program
the unofficial deal selling masterclass
you went
and started caning it yeah well i'll
tell you how it started i
i went absolutely crazy on networking
like people say how do you find
investors okay
network yeah put yourself out there i
was speaking at networking events all
over the country i was driving
all over the country to speak at netflix
do you know why because i remember when
i asked you how you found investors you
were telling me you were going to pin me
and you would drive four hours to speak
up in me for 30 minutes to drive home
and i was doing the exact same and i
remember i went down to cornwall to
speak to an event i was told to be about
40 people there
and there was like six people there and
i remember driving i thought oh my god
but i would still do it doesn't matter
um and
you coached me a little bit with
speaking in front of people and things
like that and
it was really good and then i went out
built my investors list i went out found
deals
and again i'm prepared to do whatever it
takes so i remember leaving my house one
day on a sunday morning to look at two
houses in lincoln
i got chatting to the agent she had some
more houses so i ended up staying out i
ended up being
i ended up being out away from my home
for the whole week i looked at 52 houses
that week
i sold four of them to investors while i
was on the road
two of them i was on the top of pennines
sending text messages and sending emails
and
like four houses by the end of the week
one on that week i also found a property
that i took on as a lease option
agreement
and none of it was planned at the start
of the week because property is about
people it's about relationships
so when you're getting out there and
you're speaking to agents speak to them
and listen because they've got problems
and you can fix them
and one thing i love about you and the
way we train is we that's what we train
property is about people it's about when
when fixing a solution to somebody
fixing a problem to somebody's effects
providing a solution to somebody's
problem money comes from people not
property yeah
in your case money comes from our staff
because you have them as tenants
yeah but yeah he tries to poach our
staff for tenants
do you need any houses in hall no
they're in london go away
in fact one of uh one of your very first
lease option agreements in wolverhampton
yeah
um we had some of our our tenants too
yeah which which is fine and then sam on
the academy a lot of academy members
they've got
read to service accommodation units and
all the other academy members stay there
when they go to events things like that
yeah are seated
through your lease option agreement
right from the early days
they must be getting close to well do
you know what i was actually speaking to
one of the ladies uh one of the ones
i've gotten hull that
um she's wanting to complete in it now
um and
yeah i'm like i'm in a position where i
can so i had it valued a couple of weeks
ago
um and it's it's not quite what it needs
to be valuation-wise yeah but she's
prepared to take a bit of a hit on it
just to get only like three years ago
it's two years yeah two and a half years
ago so i've got two and a half years
left in the on the agreement
yeah um so we're probably completing it
next year so how much rent
are you paying the landlord uh 420
i think it's 420 420 and you've turned
into a four bit hmr
four by hmo and up until the start of
covert it was making around 1250
1300 a month wow but then cove would
come and the tenants they were all
polish tenants they all went back to
poland the property sat empty for a good
three four months yeah but now it's
it's tenanted again so this happens it
happens yes it's a business
yeah i look at it as a business not a
hustle so yeah it's so good right that's
the difference between a business and a
hustle
well business you get business results
hustles you you don't i always say if
you're gonna treat
whatever you do treat it like a business
because you get business results if you
treat it like a hobby
you'll get hobby results and i i treat
it like a business i i
the money just sits in the bank for when
i have void periods um
and things like that so so you started
um coming to events yeah so we set up we
set a better source you're selling lots
of properties you're doing lease option
agreements you hmos
you're becoming so successful as a
property investor that i'm like
dude come down to the crash course come
down to the events
and literally just share your story on
stage because your story was so powerful
and people
sometimes people hearing it from me is
one thing oh i just did this i just did
that but sometimes they might be like
yeah but
what about your students so you start
coming along to the crash courses
and people would give you would when it
was like what was your best part of the
crash course they'd be like alistair oh
it's there
literally it was almost embarrassing i
remember reading through the feedback
forms
i i've been on stage for 12 hours you
jumped up for 15 minutes and shared the
story best part of the day i understand
calling him alice they're killing him
i'm like oh
my literally an embarrassing amount of
people so um
i approached you i was like dude you're
doing really well on the property side
yeah
i know you're coming to the crash
courses and sharing your story
i just wanted to check your free for the
next year to do that because
i need you there do you know someone um
i'm gonna
this is about you actually um 2018
and actually 2017 2017 18 i went to
every
cro i've been to every crash course
we've ever run since like since i've
been
apart from one where there was two crash
courses 17 this week
and i was running one of them there we
go
is we teach serve before you sell
yeah and you you're a big big uh
advocate of serving for yourself
and you encouraged me to serve and
that's what i was doing and it you know
what that massively helped me
in my business and in my heart and
everything
helping people before you sell to them
and it builds you up it's so good
because people would have thought like i
remember people saying oh he must be on
commission or something
and it's like no you were coming month
after month in fact week after week
we'll run them all the time just because
you wanted to help people yeah you
wanted to inspire but i know off the
back of it
you were building you know your business
and you were selling a list i was
building my list i was billed i was
selling deals yeah i was getting people
asked me to spend days well i've got
junk i've got joint ventures out of it
but what you weren't doing now
is you weren't coming to the event
sharing your story and then trying to
pitch people
you know you were just coming and
helping people i was honoring you and
the fact that i was honoring the crash
course
because the crash course is what got me
started now what what does my head and
is when people come to serve but with
the pretense of i'm
trying to come and put some customers
i've never done that never done that i
came
to serve you and the crash course and
the people at the crash course
but naturally off the back of it people
connect with me and i want to do
business and people say uh
sarah how can i get on stage at the
crash course it's like just serve sir
add value do the training go get results
become financially free come on when
it's wednesday and then
if you're asked which you will be yeah
yeah do it do a three two minute piece
yeah
travel to scotland to do a two minute
piece and then if you're good
and your heart felt yeah and and you
help people and you come up on the
feedback forms then you're gonna get
asked again and again so as a result of
that
um at the same time i'm doing more and
more events
yeah we're getting an overpopulation of
people flying in from all over the world
and um
you know you at the same time you
started doing like
i mean how many deals did you do last
year how many did you um through
yeah over 220 um 220 yeah so you're here
someone that's coming to the events
someone that loves the training
a product and a walking talking
testimonial but also someone that's
wildly successful in property so i'm
like hmm
um i've got all these training events
i've got a couple kids and different
things
so i thought well actually maybe i could
train you
yeah to be a trainer and and maybe you
could start helping
with some of the events yeah and uh talk
to me about how i
approached you with that and what
happened do you know something um before
we get into that right
i've always felt i was destined to be on
stage from
10 15 years ago i remember watching um
i can't remember who it was but it was
this guy was on stage delivering our
seminar and i thought that's what i want
to do i want to be on stage help people
and then i met you and then you're on
stage and i'm like
oh my goodness me this this guy's crazy
like he's delivering amazing
and he's helping all these people and i
thought that's i want to be like that
it's so weird that he felt like that
though because
no one would have known and i wouldn't
know you're in the audience with your
arms folded with your glasses like
tips i saw the other day on a youtube a
video over a crash course
the crash cause i went to and like
everyone's standing up clapping and i'm
sitting there like this
i guess do we know that you're thinking
i want to be a trainer one day
i know this is the video pan don't like
but the way it come about was you yeah
you approached me you said luke you need
to go on stage and you need to train
yeah and because you're such a walking
testimonial of it you've got to give it
a question
i created another training program just
for you yeah you did actually tell the
world
tell the world it just wasn't called
that it was tell the world okay
leaders create leaders they don't create
followers great
and you you're a big advocate for that
you create or you empower other people
to lead and you've done that with me
done that with somebody else as well now
we went mean that other person came
along um and we
we spent three four hours with you just
talking about how to train and how to
speak to people and how to help people
and how to
how to help uh speak from stage and all
sorts of stuff and then
that led to me doing an hour piece at an
event and then another an hour and a
half piece and then at two sessions
and then before no i was running an
event a three-day event and a four-day
event and it's like
yeah deep end here i come the thing is
that when you
when you've got the knowledge to be a
trainer i mean first things first to be
a trainer
you have to have first-hand experience
of course yeah and you were doing deals
day in and day out you had deals that
have gone wrong deals have gone right
yeah
you're also when you first came in
you're teaching
our stuff yeah right because i another
thing is i think to be
it's you know you've got to be so
careful i i see people
you know they've got one rent to rent
deal and then they start mentoring
people how to be a
rent to rent and it's like oh like i'm
not going to judge
no no but you just have to you have to
be so careful because
it's crazy you need you need a few years
experience you need a bit of
you need backing yeah you need you need
to have the right insurances
you there's so much that you need i mean
geez if you think selling
property deals you need to be compliant
and need to do it properly if you're
training people how to do stuff yeah
it's it's a very different it's a very
it's a main field
you came and you came on under our
umbrella with our support and teachings
and then we're able to
blossom you're on stage you've got over
a thousand people yeah
you know i never thought that no never
would i have ever thought
we sent you out to the rural parts of
africa in the villages
to stand on stage and teach business and
you know so your whole
your whole you just blew up man you know
yeah i did i i absolutely did i agree
with that
um but it comes from practice because
we can teach anybody the skills of
public speaking but what they will not
get is the practice and the stage time
that's what they need yeah and what i
love about you is you've always been
very much
there's the stage yeah have fun yeah as
long as you're delivering and teaching
what we want you to teach
have fun and i remember because i've
because i'm sorry because i'm because
i'm true to who i
am yeah and i'm walking the walk it's a
very
it's it's easy and it gets easier and
easier and easier with time i don't even
get nervous now and
it's i've watched you on stage for years
and i've seen you how you do i've seen
how you deliver
and i deliver as much as i can as best i
can i give everything to me
you know what though dude as a as not
just as a property
investor and a property entrepreneur but
as a trainer yeah
you are world class thank you you know
and it's a it's honestly i know i taught
you and you've obviously got a lot of
stage time and stuff we used to
you do it you do it you do an hour piece
and then we'd meet up and we'd spend
10 hours studying what you did you know
what you know what i love about you
right is most people when you go on
stage right you'll do like an hour and a
half on stage
and you'll come off and every everyone
will be like yes man you killed it you
smashed it
and you'd be like yeah you're done all
right but here's three things to do
better next time yeah and that don't
that's not a bad thing i love that yeah
because i want constructive
feedback yeah that's what i don't want
somebody to blow smoke up my ass because
they like me or because they won't
they think i need it i want somebody
that's to say
you've done all right you've done good
but next time do this
so because you were you were giving me
really good positive constructive
feedback
every time i got better and better and
better yeah and it's just crazy you know
what though
you're right but you can't you can't
sometimes
it's really good to take criticism but
you have to sometimes only take
criticism for people that are better
than you hundred percent you know what
i'm saying 100
everyone loves to throw their two
pennies yeah everyone loves to throw
their two pennies yeah but but now
honestly as a trainer and the great
thing the satisfying thing for me is
you know obviously i'm running training
and i'm teaching people and all that and
it's great i've got winners wednesday
every week
but now you're a trainer yeah and the
rippling effect it's crazy
and that's what being the leader is
there's only there's only there's no
room for egos in business
i agree with that you know it's not it's
not about trying to be the one or trying
to be the best or trying
it's about actually how can my message
reach as many people
and if you look at all the leaders
throughout history they've always raised
up other leaders
yeah so you know i'm wow proud of what
you've done and who you've become
and also on the property side as well
let's not forget you've got a lot of
juicy deals going on right now
yeah i haven't even been to some of your
deals i need to go down to bedford yeah
are really good i've never been to tell
me tell me about that but bedford
um is it's a three bed end it's sort of
four bed end terrace
um it's in a really good area that's
just become article four
so i bought it pre-article four no one
r4 was coming
and you've got the permission now
grandfather's right so done man boom
it's all sorted um and i made it into a
i was gonna go six bed hmo but i decided
to go slightly bigger rooms so i went
for five bid hmo
um but yeah it's a brilliant deal and
she paid for it two hundred and ten
thousand
and two hundred and ten what's the
rooftop cost uh 50k i've allowed for it
and that included some structural issues
because i had some structures
260 all in value 350. oh my goodness
but that's minimum um now the reason
i've done a lot of research
this is gonna be a five bed a hmo so i
reckon it's gonna come back about 360
370.
but the nearest three bed is 320 and
there's only
there's no other four beds i've sold
nearby so you're just gonna refinance it
pull your money out
yeah rent it out how much cash flow will
that give you each month well okay
so i've already got somebody lined up to
take off my hands give me two and a half
thousand pound a month
um or i can rent it do it privately and
i'll get about three and a half hours
that's financial freedom from that one
deal no
and it's going to be like most of my
money back if
probably all of my money back if it
comes in at 350 i'll get i'll leave it
two or three thousand pound in there
if i if it comes like 360 or money back
so so it's a bang
and that's the thing you know what you
don't have to work no
that one deal well notice that one deal
i mean geez you've systemized your
sourcing company have you systemized the
sourcing company uh do you know what
because again i'm a leader so i found
somebody
and i empowered them to run that
business and i just manage them
so i just speak to them i speak to them
every day so you've got like two or
three members of staff yeah
with my business run the business i've
seen it and i think
there's two three members of staff and
then co-sources yes and then they manage
them i manage them
right and that's it and then all you do
my friend i have to just
expose you right now please is you have
like pretty much a weekly
a weekly management meeting which
probably lasts 10 minutes yeah so hey
max hey how you doing what's going on
quick zoom call yeah
check the figures are implied check
things are okay look at the kpis key
performance indicators yeah and then go
great and then take your nice nice check
yeah every month
we get a decent decent payment from it
again obviously i mean
i get my check as well right business i
get my check as well it's all good but
do you know what it's all good it's
business and
it's just one english every month though
you know you've got a you've got a
passive income
and the money they're coming from the
source in i mean geez look it's it's
it's big money
it's not it's it's big money it's big
money
people i like it so do i i like it i hit
the jackpot with alastair cunningham i
hate the jackpot
but it's good but then what's that
you're welcome
yeah but but then but then it's
reciprocal it's business
what we've got is friendship but also
it's business and
business capitalism is a beautiful thing
i agree with you it's a beautiful thing
listen three four years ago i was
working my ass off to earn three four
grand a month yeah
now i'm working i'm still working my ass
off but i'm earning that damn side more
money but you know when i'm working a
lot smarter
here's the crazy thing right your
passive income is considerably more than
it used to be when you're working your
ass off yes everything you do now is
from a position of because you want to
choice that's the thing yeah yeah all
the speaker stuff you don't get paid a
great deal for that no
of course you get paid you have to uh
and you know
that's all good but you do that because
the same reason i do that it's mission
you want to
do you know something somebody asked me
a couple of weeks ago uh when i was on
stage i said look i don't got any
questions
and somebody said look why do you travel
around spend a lot of time in hotels
speaking on stage and helping people
and i'm like because it truly
is because i see people coming to the
academy come through the system
and they're like on two grand a month
and then jamie higgs take jamie higgs
yeah
working in a factory working as a in our
um a logistical warehouse okay
doing what he's doing earning a decent
salary within months he's now got pat
he's now quit his job he's employed
someday he's got passive income about
eight and a half nine thousand pound a
month i think
but it's just like and that's all from
the training that we've delivered that
we've showed how to do and it's like
it's just crazy but you see normal
everyday people
transforming their life by taking action
by learning the skills
that rich people don't want to teach
that's why i do what i do they don't
well you're
you're actually you're actually the
mission that you're on which is the same
mission that i'm on
it's a noble mission and you can vouch
because
you're a trainer now they don't like it
no they don't get attacked
by the media we get we get silent
yeah um you know i don't get anywhere
near the sort of abuse you get
but i mean bring it on bring it up i
don't care i don't bother me no
because i've got thick skin because i
know that i know we're helping people
you know
the thing is though when you know your
purpose in life
when you know your mission you can see
the results
people's opinions don't matter you know
so i know they used to used to do matter
for you yes
i remember the i'm gonna tell the story
now i remember when you've got your
first bad review on your book yeah
a couple years ago now at least you got
your bad review you rang me up
and you were like dude i'm so angry this
person look what they said
what they said i need to ring them up
and i need to give them a piece of my
mind
and let's get this and i was like dude
if you can't take the heat get out the
kitchen yeah
you you're very much like that like
honestly if you can't take a bad review
and you're like it's not a legitimate
review they've not even read the book
even in here they say
and i'm like but dude like honestly this
is just yeah
this is this is being in the kitchen
brother yeah do you want this or not do
you want it do you want to be on stage
do you want to be empowering people do
you want to be because you
you can't have you can't have all of the
satisfaction of helping people and
changing lives and
and all that without having some people
i i agree with that and but i never used
to i used to i used to really
use all the stuff you used to see online
used to go mad she's like oh samuel i
used to remember have you seen what they
said about you online i'm like dude
i don't care yeah i'm not interested i
if it's that bad
that it needs taking down my lawyers
will deal with it yeah i'm not
interested
i'm busy looking at my customers and in
fairness i i can now
relate to that because i'm like that now
i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't care um but i used to how do you
learn how do you learn because people
ask me all the time
they said to me how do you deal with the
heat and hey
and the people you know the higher
powers but also the fruity poor people
that are just jealous
because there's both you got you got the
you know i had someone yesterday
i don't know if you saw the video i had
someone yesterday said to me um samuel
go and get a real job
right go get a real job and firstly i
was thinking straight away i was
thinking
as an entrepreneur we don't go get jobs
we create jobs we create jobs okay
but secondly we create this for people
like him yes
maybe not people like him because we
wouldn't employ a troll no i click on
him and guess what he says looking for
work he's unemployed
of course you're telling me to go and
get a job
right i've got a business last year
turned over 10 million pounds yeah
clean profit of 2 million guess what
that means that means i'm paying
hundreds of thousands of pounds in taxes
to the government
who are paying your benefits yeah so
why would you bite the hand that feeds
you as a why would you not
champion entrepreneurs champion
businesses
this is capitalism yeah but people don't
get it because they're stupid yeah
i get i understand that as well so
you've got those haters then you've got
the higher powers
yeah you know which which exist but
don't want
because if you think about this think
about this right we got the government
saying help to buy schemes
isis pushing you to go down this put
money in the bank
banks the banks want your money right
the banks want your money why so they
can invest it and they can give you zero
percent
yeah right when we stand there and say
actually don't do that
here's what you should do instead be
financially independent don't rely on
the government
don't work 40 hours a week for 40 years
to retire 40 percent of what you
couldn't afford to live in the first
place
don't do the help to buy school mr sham
do this instead like to think that and
then get a thousand people
every time you run an event well we are
we're getting so many people
it's for dave we've had 700 tickets
booked in the last week i know
i know it's ridiculous but to answer
your questions why i can deal with the
hit the online hate now and all that
is because do you know what they're not
customers they're not clients
they're not generally people that have
paid money to come into the train the
people we care about are people that
have actually paid money
and then they've sent us messages saying
alastair samuel do you know what you've
changed my life yeah
like i got a message last week from a
guy who he just come to a program
recently
and he's been dealing with something for
the last 20 odd years and he's never
he's he's never had the courage to speak
out about that until now because after
we've
done some training and it's like that's
who i care about i care about these
people not the people
that i've never done the training that
are just given an opinion of an opinion
of an opinion
yeah i care about the people we're
helping and the messages i get every
single day from people saying aliso
your books inspired me alistair your
youtube's inspired me alistair just seen
you do this deals inspired me
even just yesterday on facebook live in
bedford and i got messages from a guy
who lives in bedford
he's he's got some money to invest he
wants to invest in property
he's been following me and your's
journey and he's like
great you've inspired me so much i'm now
gonna and i want to quit my job and do
property full-time
how can i do some training or how can i
get involved
that's what i like i care about the
people we help and we inspire
um that's right and because i i went
through some bad times before i got
involved in property
like everyone has and people read my
book and then they're like
well here you've done it when we met you
actually you have severe depression yeah
i'm not gonna yeah
absolutely you know absolutely and and
so many people yeah
um absolutely and and do you know what
if i'm if i tell that story from stage
or if i tell that story in my book and
it helps one person that's my job done
yeah and i've done that
i've done that with jacob with all of
many people i've had my books reached
worldwide
i've had people from australia from
america read my book and say wow
mason book amazing story tell me about
the training you've done tell me about
how you got here
so that's why i do what i do yeah not
because the one
loser who's broke says oh it's a scam
come on mate grow up
it's like geez no it's it's it's silly i
mean you just have to look at the
customer's feedback yeah 100
yeah i mean it's silly and and you see
the independent surveys
yeah in fact we published them yeah what
was the last event that that we did the
last deal selling mustache was the
feeling last week
uh on average 9.5 out of 10. 9.5 out of
10. that means that
and no one scored it less than a nine i
think it was just consistent of nines
and tens
every person in the room like of course
they would because when you do what i
did to you where you're like look guys
let's sell a deal in front of you and
then ding ding ding ding ding ding
last week do you sell mass class sold
two deals seven grand in the bank
yeah how can they deny that how can like
you cannot see
and see that you can't see it because
once you've seen it how can you go back
and do what
exactly for two thousand pound a month
when you just saw it made in in two
hours and you know what there's
there's no other trainer in the country
no apart from odds they can do that
no because they haven't got the database
they haven't got the list they haven't
got the the
the reputation no i haven't got it and
and and i'll tell you something as well
that there's the property skill you know
people say oh you don't need to go on
the courses
everyone that says that people that
haven't done it and are getting no
results
having a bash they're having a bash
they're like oh you don't need to go on
the courses
but like you do 100
how many people viewed that bedford
house uh 43
do you know i was speaking to the agent
beforehand and i was the 44th person to
view that house and everyone else said
no
thanks do you know what put them off
like they went in the house and the
whole
upstairs was being held up by actual
props so they were holding the ceiling
up because
there had been an extension built that
hadn't been built properly so it had the
walls went tied in so as a result the
walls were just separate
um and there was some cracking and
there's some structural issues
um and and i came in and with my
knowledge and also with my connections
from the
academy i spoke to some other academy
members who know
a lot more about that than i do yeah and
i said look this is what's happening
this can i send you some images and they
sent it over um
the quote to fix the structural stuff
was 36 000 pound that's what the staging
gave me they got written quote 36 grand
with the knowledges and with the
empowerment with the people in the
academy
i got that done for less than four less
than four grand
that's the thing people say that academy
is expensive i just saved three times
the cost of the academy in that one deal
yeah and that's one people knowledge
people that's one of hundreds of deals
as well yeah so it's like
if you want to be a professional
anything you want to be a professional
like
basketball player you're going to pay a
coach you want to be a doctor a lawyer
a hairdresser unless you chop someone's
ear you need to go to college
yeah i need to pay for that yeah
property is the most lucrative
profession on the planet you want to
have the choices like what you've got
now the choices to speak or to travel to
whatever you want
and you want to have financial freedom
property is the best way to get there
you want to learn that skill
then and luckily most of our training is
free yeah it is
yeah and again the crash course it's
amazing
yeah the crash course is really where it
starts you know the crash course is just
and people think the crash course is
just going to be you know like uh you
know are
a bit of a sales pitch and this and a
bit it's like no
on the crash course i will on stage find
a deal from scratch calculate the roi
call the agent show you exactly what to
do step by step yeah there are
additional training if you want
but um i'm so glad you took the
additional training so am i do you know
what i
absolutely am and i would i i say this
all the time
i would pay for that training 10 times
over yeah i would because
of what i've what i've how much i've
made
the connections i've got the friends
that i've got the network that i've got
the
the the knowledge the the mindset shift
the change in my
heart the change in my soul everything i
would it's changed
everything for me hey you don't
understand how much has changed for me
because it's changed
the biggest things changes up there yeah
because it means i believe in myself
and do you know when you believe in
yourself you're unstoppable and like i'm
going to be a big
big force to be reckoned with dude you
already are um and you're just getting
started
and it all started by seeing you on tv
and attending the crash course yeah and
i think as well
like with your journey i really believe
you're just getting started man i do as
well
you know you're just getting started
i've never believed it so much as i do
know
yeah well dude i'm just i've got nothing
else to say apart from massive respect
i admire you as a trainer as well
because people think as a trainer it's
just like
all the glory and you know it's you are
serving
it is hard let me tell you something
only bad trainers want all the glory
yeah the good trainers like us it's not
about us it's about the people out there
yeah exactly and it's a it's not it's
people might see the pictures on stage
you know like a thousand people and
think
but no this is hard hard graft
and by the way the money either i can't
even afford to take a salary
from the training business because it's
so bad
yeah the money is so bad yeah as a
businessman
i'll laugh at the training business i
laugh at it as a businessman
no thanks i'll rather sell deals to
people yeah rather than teach them how
to find deals themselves
but the the missionary in me yeah the
financial evangelist as
i've been called by the media as a slur
i take it
i take it i take it as a a compliment
i'm a financial advisor you know i want
to talk to you about that quickly don't
don't don't end up
i want to talk about that this the the
mission right people's
people i used to be one of these people
right they would hear something going on
about their mission i'm like yeah
[ __ ] right that's that was me
like somebody would stand on stage and
say yeah it's all about the mission of
help people and i was like utter
bs right and i would and i'd probably
say it with you as well okay
but then you invited me out to uganda
now what we had a one-to-one meeting
back three years ago and you gave me
12-month goals right and you said as i
was leaving you said no you're not doing
12 months is too long do that in three
months if you do it in three months
i'll bring you out to uganda so we came
we went to uganda 2018
and i saw firsthand what you've been
doing out there
like you can see you can watch it on a
video yeah you can watch it on a video
that's fine easy
but when you're there first hand and
you're seeing the children like that do
you know the little
in the first africa video there's a
little child and somebody takes the ball
from him
yeah well i met him i saw him yeah and
when you see it first hand
again you can't unsee it yeah and like
for that like that alone i know
i know i know you as a person from that
just from from being up there
seeing the impact you've had seen the
change and seeing what's happened in the
villages with charles and
the charities that he's running that
you've supported it's it's it's really
admirable definitely
and you know what again you know i don't
even really do videos about that i kind
of
i just crack on with it and that i've
been going out to rural parts of africa
since i was a teenager yeah you know i
mean for me that that's just been
in grinding me to help other people now
obviously we're out bringing education
schools
water and different things and again
having you out there sorry i couldn't
stick around for the whole trip
well dude you had an excuse yeah no we
we we we were on a boat and i broke my
leg we both fell off the boat we were
from
you almost died we bought it i almost
died and you ended up
bruised no forget me like yeah fine i
was bruised and i've still got
twisted pelvis to this day but um and i
still got a chiropractor three times a
week for it but
i remember when you bust your leg
it's still not weird it's still weirdly
shaped
right you bust your leg and i remember
getting pulled in from the it they took
them about an hour to find me and anna
they pulled us in and i'm like where is
everyone's everyone all right and then
you were at the front of this boat and i
thought our sign was fine
i didn't and you went because you
weren't screaming you weren't shouting
you were just stood there and you're
like is everyone alright it's overnight
and i noticed your leg was over the
front of the boat
and then there was a bandage on it i
just thought you bruised it and it's
only when i come over and i saw the
blood
and like and you you obviously bit of
bone sticking out and
you broke your leg but you weren't
screaming and shouting at that point
your concern was only about
where is my team yeah and i remember you
didn't say you weren't like
[ __ ] my legs said oh get me get me a
doctor get my dog you went like that you
were like where is everybody where's
alistair where's where's everybody
that's and everyone was telling me that
and then we waited
three hours for somebody to come pick us
up and we were in the rural parts of
ginger
somebody come picked us up and we all
got crammed into the back of this
six-seater minibus
and you were in the back seat and you
were leaning against the window and i
was underneath you
and you were leaning here and you had i
was supporting your leg
and we couldn't move your leg because
obviously you broke it and it was every
time you move you go over bump you're
screaming you're in agony
i was covered in your blood i was all
your blood all over my leg and um
i remember you started passing out yeah
you were like blacking out and i started
shouting at you
and i thought like i'm sitting here
shouting it's time elites tell them to
wake up and tell them to stop that
you're not gonna you're not [ __ ]
going here and i remember that i don't
know if you how much you remember of
that
yeah but then we got into into um it was
it was it was horrifying me i'm telling
you that was the scariest moment in my
life
because i thought i was gonna die i
thought i thought you were i didn't know
where you were
shooting and shooting up yeah it was
yeah it was literally shooting every
time
it was it was just squirting out and um
it was just crazy and we got to the
hospital like
if what felt like i always remember
saying the driver how long five minutes
five minutes
an hour later how long five minutes five
minutes three four hours later
we arrived at this hospital and we i
remember we
pulled the van up bed came out took you
away
we all then got out i walked across the
hallway and i collapsed i passed out
and it was just yeah and then you
obviously
lost shed loads of your blood yeah 45
percent of my blood i lost
lost loads away you were like different
guy and i remember we were all
shooking up and it was so i've been
there firsthand and and even then you
were like
the mission still goes on yeah we were
all like dude we need to call this a day
and you're like no
you're lying there in a bed losing your
blood your eyes were all
um bloodshot and bruised and whatever
and then you're like nope the mission
goes on
yeah and we continued with the mission
yeah i remember saying
is anyone else not fit to continue with
the mission and everyone was like we're
all
a bit in a bad way but i was like right
i can't i gotta have an operation
yeah but in that case we saw your new
team leader yeah crack on
go find the next water well we're
building because we've got stuff to do
we can't just neglect
we can't just neglect the mission and
that's the thing's temporary into
yeah yeah that's what i said um that's
where i got that from yeah you said that
there our pain is temporary
yeah and you're how true is that totally
true it's temporary but there's people
right here that need water that needs
support and
we're we've booked a week and we're
gonna go make it happen and i think
you know what to become financially free
you just need to get a bit of basic
skill 100 to become ultimately
financially free you just need some
skills
but i think to become um a true a true
leader
someone that really brings change and
stuff you've got to have a strong
pulling mission and you've got that i've
got that
it's a real pleasure man and uh dude i
love you so much
thank you thank you for coming on the
show thank you thank you for um
thank you for being the only person i
trust to run the samuel leads training
events right now
there's no one else there's a lead
trainer apart from you right now and i'm
sure that between us we'll train more
people up in time yeah but uh honestly
mad respect so
guys if you enjoyed that please do me a
massive favor drop a comment below
what was your favorite part of the
interview comment below and i'll chop
that a little bit and i'll put that on
instagram and on socials
also if you want to come to the crash
course i'm going to leave a link in the
description
you can come along for completely free
if you're watching this relatively
quickly after the interview
we're running a crash course on friday
this week and
next week as well i'll be there alice
they'll be there and it's going to be
absolutely incredible it's free and
there's no catch
and it all starts with the crash course
so get booked on below thanks for
watching
peace out subscribe i'll see you next
time see you guys